digamos que empezamos con la siguiente
ecuación 2 x menos 1 esto es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 8 menos x y bueno
observa que tenemos un radical por lo
tanto hablemos de esta ecuación radical
y como solamente lo tenemos de un lado
de la ecuación entonces podemos decir
vamos a eliminar el radical elevando al
cuadrado ambos lados de la ecuación
entonces podemos decir que esto sería lo
mismo que 2 x menos 1 esto a su vez
elevado al cuadrado y esto va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 8 menos x
todo esto elevado al cuadrado y bueno de
este lado que vamos a obtener vamos a
obtener 4x cuadrada menos
4 x +
estás de acuerdo y de este otro lado
vamos a obtener 8 menos x ahora aquí hay
que ser muy cuidadosos porque podemos
sentir que hicimos puras operaciones
legítimas hicimos lo mismo en ambos
lados de la ecuación y entonces puedes
pensar que estas dos son ecuaciones
equivalentes pero de hecho no son
exactamente equivalentes porque cuando
el debas algo al cuadrado una manera de
verlo es que pierdes información por
ejemplo si nos tomamos por aquí déjame
ponerlo con este color 2 x menos uno
menos uno
esto es igual a menos la raíz cuadrada
de 8 menos x
bueno pues si eleva a ambos lados al
cuadrado de esta ecuación vas a obtener
exactamente lo mismo ya que un negativo
al cuadrado se vuelve positivo entonces
cuando estamos buscando una solución
para esta ecuación y no para esta
ecuación tenemos que probar que nuestra
solución
la verdadera solución a nuestra primera
actuación y no una solución a esta
ecuación demorado y es por eso que vamos
a llamar a esta solución una solución
extraña pero bueno vamos a ver si
podemos resolver esto y para eso voy a
escribir esta cuadrática en forma
estándar y bueno lo que voy a hacer es
restar 8 de ambos lados de la ecuación
restar 8 de ambos lados de la ecuación y
sumar x de ambos lados de la ecuación
sumar x de ambos lados de la ecuación y
que voy a obtener bueno pues vamos a
obtener 4x cuadrada 4x cuadrada menos 4
x más x eso es lo mismo que menos 3x y
después 1 menos 8 es lo mismo que menos
7 y esto va a ser igual
y bueno para resolver esto de aquí
podemos podemos factorizar o bueno tal
vez podemos creo que es mejor usar la
fórmula general así que vamos a
utilizarla por aquí las soluciones de
esta ecuación son bueno pues es menos b
entonces me va a quedar 3 positivo más
menos la raíz cuadrada de b elevado al
cuadrado menos 3 al cuadrado es 9 menos
cuatro veces a a vale 4 por ser se vale
menos 7 x menos 7 ok y todo esto a su
vez está dividido entre dos veces a dos
por cuatro
es 8 muy bien entonces x va a ser igual
a 3 más menos la raíz cuadrada de 9 aquí
tengo menos por menos es más y 4x4 es 16
bueno eso es lo mismo que 70 42 mejor
hagámoslo por aquí 16 por 7 muy bien 7
por 6 42 y llevamos 47 por unas 74 11
112 muy bien déjame quitar todo esto de
aquí y vamos a poner 112 112 y después
todo esto entre otros
ok entonces x va a ser de la forma 3 más
menos la raíz cuadrada de 121 está de
lujo porque esto va a ser muy simple
entre 8 lo que quiere decir que x es de
la forma 3 más menos 11 entre 8 dicho de
otra manera o x toma el valor de 3 + 11
14 entre 8 y 14 entre 8
x toma la forma de 3 menos 11 3 11 es
menos 8 entre 8 es menos 1 y bueno
seguramente estás tentado a decir que
encontramos dos soluciones de esta
ecuación radical pero recuerda que una
de estas soluciones puede ser solución
de esta ecuación radical alternativa la
cual se perdió cuando elevamos al
cuadrado a ambos lados de esta ecuación
así que vamos a tener cuidado y vamos a
asegurarnos que estas sean soluciones
legítimas y no sean una solución extraña
de hecho es muy probable que sea una
solución extraña a esta ecuación radical
que tenemos aquí arriba la cual recuerda
no es nuestra meta principal ok entonces
veamos si me tomo el valor de menos 1 si
me tomo el valor de menos 1 que obtengo
bueno pues voy a obtener 2 que
multiplica a menos 1 estoy sustituyendo
aquí menos 1 esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada
8 - menos 1 muy bien y 2 x menos 1 - 2 -
1 - 3 - 3 es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
9 y ojo porque aquí estamos tomando la
raíz cuadrada positiva la raíz principal
entonces esto no es cierto lo que quiere
decir que esté menos 1 es una solución
extraña solución extraña de hecho es una
solución a esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí y es más puedes verificarlo si
sustituye en esta ecuación de aquí este
valor de menos uno me quedaría dos por
menos uno menos uno
esto es igual a menos la raíz cuadrada
de 8 - menos 1 y bueno esto sabemos que
vale menos 3 y de este lado me va a
quedar menos la raíz principal de 9 lo
cual es 3
entonces me va a quedar menos 3 entonces
observa que llegamos a la solución
ecuación alternativa que recuerda no era
lo que buscábamos por lo tanto esta no
es solución de la ecuación que queríamos
y ahora si podemos estar seguros que
esta va a ser nuestra solución 14 entre
8 va a ser la solución de esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí y es más puedes
comprobarlo por tu cuenta de hecho te
invito a que lo hagas